[Music]
all right children it's a new decade
it's time to face the facts how do I put
this delicately your humble Hostess is a
total
Les shame you're probably worried this
is a coming out video and I'm sorry to
tell you that it is but oh it's it's so
much worse than just that you know one
coming out May Be regarded as a
misfortune two looks like carelessness
and three well at that point you're just
doing it for attention and I do love
attention I want to be very clear about
that but I also happen to be gay some
gay people love attention it's been
known to happen so there Comes A Time in
a woman's life when you have to take a
step back look yourself in the mirror
and admit this is some highkey Les
vitious behavior and I'm going to talk
you through how I got to that point so
story time I fell in love with my best
friend story time telling my boyfriend
I'm a lesbian Story Time my parents
walked in on my Taco Bell mukbang
exposed graphic the tea is piping hot
for a long time on this channel the
official story has been that I'm by I'm
a super [ __ ] byy but I haven't dated
women since I transitioned and for a
while there I got pretty deep into the
the straight lifestyle this really
started in 2018 by that summer I had
privately convinced myself that I was a
fully heterosexual woman and we're going
to circle back to how I reached that
conclusion but I'm starting in the
middle of things I'm like an epic poet
hey Muse hey how are you Gorge so at the
beginning of 2018 I became close friends
I'd even say best friends with a woman
whom style
call Joanne light of my life can we get
some melodramatic music please yeah here
we go you're going to want to pour
yourself a glass of something nice I
want you to fully enjoy my pain so my
friendship with Joanne got very intense
very fast it was that kind of friendship
where you develop your own private
language of references and in jokes and
you drive everyone around you crazy with
your unintelligible banter we'd call
each other pretty much every day and
we'd talk for hours and I don't think
I've ever called her and not been
laughing or smiling in the first 20
seconds which is very unusual for me cuz
I am a weird and I don't get along that
well with that many people one reason we
got so emotionally close is we're both
trans and there's a kind of intuitive
understanding and a sense of humor that
I can share with another trans woman
that I can't really have with anyone
else oh and by the way Joanne also
happens to be just angelically beautiful
which I did notice every time I looked
at her and from the beginning of this
relationship it wasn't sexual but it
wasn't exactly platonic either we'd get
drunk drunk make out we'd sleep in the
same bed and cuddle Straight girls do
that right G Pals I remember one of the
first times I hung out with Joanne we we
got our nails done together and that
night we were bar hopping and she took
my pretty hand and her pretty hand and
we walked down the street together
holding hands this is this is garbage
and I want to die I hope you all know
that that I'm an Agony later we were at
a bar table with friends and every time
one of us needed a drink we'd run off to
the bar and she'd secretly kiss me ah
it's this still one of the most magical
gay things that's ever happened to me
Joan had a boyfriend at the time but he
didn't care a lot of men think girls
kissing is hot but they don't take it
seriously they don't think it could ever
mean anything or lead to a real
relationship G
Pals just kill me take me out behind the
shed put me down humanely and just buy a
new YouTuber before the kids get home
and they won't notice so this very
intimate friendship went on for about a
year without me acknowledging to Joanne
or to myself that I was falling in love
so Not only was I in denial about being
in love with her but at the same time I
had basically convinced myself that I
only wanted to date men so how could I
possibly think that well the short
answer is shame why is no one talking
about the shame I was so ashamed of my
attraction to women there were days I
thought the shame was going to crush me
to death oh I wanted to be straight so
bad and let no no one say I didn't make
a strong attempt there should honestly
be a statue of me sucking dick in the
town square with the inscription here
nelt Natalie win attempted heterosexual
I'm a bronze star lesbian well if we're
really being honest I don't think I get
a star oh I was desperate to be straight
I tried prayer I tried electric shocks
all the classics all the hits you know
the idea is if you shock yourself every
time you think about women you start to
associate the two in your head so now
I'm a lesan and I enjoy electric
[Music]
shocks this is supposed to hurt but I
just feel like I'm on a road trip with
Kate Blanchet so at some point the shame
was just too much for me and it
literally broke my brain I no longer
wanted to be straight I simply duded
myself into thinking I was straight
maybe a little by a little bit by that
time I started dating men and I got into
a serious long-term relationship with a
man and at first I explained away my
feelings for Joanne by telling myself
female friends ship are just really
intense that's probably why I feel so
strongly and everyone thinks women are
beautiful so it's only natural I notice
that and you
know spend a lot of time thinking about
it so this nonsense went on until the
beginning of last year and then two
things happened first Joanne started
dating a CIS
[Music]
lesbian [ __ ] my drve right I think
before that I always knew she was by but
some combination of self-interested
denial and B phobia allowed me to write
off my initial crush on her as I just
have a thing for my Straight best friend
like who doesn't but that's a very
self-serving narrative because it
quarantines your feelings inside the
safety of unattainable fantasy and it
Wards off the pain of potential
rejection cuz that way it's not really
me she's rejecting it's just she's just
not that into women but once she started
dating women I couldn't tell myself that
anymore and the jealousy hit me so hard
I I couldn't ignore it second around
that same time Joanne decided to visit
me for a few weeks it was a longdistance
friendship and about halfway through
that visit I cracked one morning I woke
up next to her G pal and I looked at her
pretty [ __ ] face and I had the
thought I want to wake up next to you
every day of my life and that is a
pretty alarming thought for a petite
heterosexual bio girl to have about her
galp pal oh never in my life have I
fallen so deeply in love with someone
like what the [ __ ] is this what am I
feeling I was experiencing an intensity
of emotion that has no right to exist
outside of 19th century Italian opera so
I confessed my feelings to Joanne and
love confession gone wrong
devastating she did not reciprocate my
feelings nurse my pain is at a 10 I need
more pills need this to say my heart was
shattered I cried a sea of Tears blah
blah blah I'm sure we all know how that
goes and here's the thing if we'd taken
a 3-month friendship break right then
and there I might have recovered but we
couldn't keep away from each other she
wasn't in love with me but she must have
been in something with me because the
truth is we were never just gal Pals and
I was Beyond Reason like I probably
would have started one of those lesbian
couple joint Instagram accounts that's
how tragic this got those are great by
the way pay no attention to Queens so
for the rest of 2019 Joanne and I kept
talking kept visiting each other and I
just repeated this heartbreak again and
again and again now if she had
reciprocated my feelings I probably
would have come out as gay last year
because the heat of a romantic
relationship has a way of evaporating
shame but rejection and heartbreak are
shameful in themselves and only made the
situation worse so I spent most of 2019
going in and out of denial until finally
last October I got super [ __ ]
canceled on Twitter as disussed in my
last video link in the description
subscribe and at the same time Joanne
realized that she was going to have to
be the one to enforce a friendship break
otherwise I was never going to get over
her so there was this combination of
things being politically canceled by
Twitter being romantically canceled by
Joanne and also losing her as my closest
friend which sent me into this catatonic
Rock Bottom kind of depression and of
course depression is a terrible thing
but I think it can also serve a purpose
because depression brings your life to a
stance still and in the quiet of that
stand still you sometimes feel outside
yourself and with that comes A New
Perspective so last December when I was
lying around drinking white claw all day
and binge watching Orange Is The Bluest
L word I actually didn't feel so much
shame anymore and that gave me a new
kind of clarity I looked back on the
last couple years and saw that I'd been
avoiding the obvious so that's what it
took for me to finally face the fact
that I am a uh I am a gay not
[Music]
clickbait Adam's a great guy and all but
I want Lilith
[Music]
shame this Floral Fantasy is a little
less mother of mankind and a little more
Coachella 2015 well that's my Eden candy
flipping I love it okay let's Circle
back and talk about how a wholesome homo
like me wound up in the clutches of the
straight agenda it starts with denial
and there's two sides to gay denial
first there was a period where I
repressed or explained away my
attraction to women female friendships
are just really intense straight girl
girls have girl crushes too and second I
experienced and acted on what I
genuinely thought was sexual and
romantic attraction to men and to be
honest I'm still kind of struggling to
make sense of all this maybe I'm not
quite ready to make this video but I'm
afraid that if I don't the shame will
overpower me again and I'll slide back
into denial so while I'm still thinking
semi clearly let me talk you through the
struggle because like most queer people
I find nothing more fascinating than an
in-depth analysis of my own personality
she's Libra so in 2017 I started taking
feminizing hormones and most people are
aware of the more obvious effects of
that like it makes you grow breaths at
least in theory I just added
progesterone we'll see if that does
anything but the Lesser known thing is
it has some pretty major effects on your
mood and your sexuality the first few
months I was on hormones I actually
wondered if I was now asexual because
the libido I had known before was just
gone but I'm very much not asexual it
just took me a while to adjust to an
endocrinologically female sex drive one
of the differences for me is it's not as
obvious now whom I'm attracted too just
looking at an attractive person well
let's put it this way it sparks my
interest but it doesn't Light My Fire
it's not the instant Inferno that is
testosterone fueled lust it's a slow
burn that has to be built up some people
call this Demi seexual which is a term
I'm ambivalent about but I think the
concept it described applies to me like
I form little crushes on People based on
watching their YouTube videos or
whatever but I don't feel intense sexual
attraction to anyone until I've gotten
close to them as a friend so I have a
hard time getting too excited about
casual dating you know can't I just find
a new best friend fall insanely in love
with her and then get gay married I know
that's not how it works I have to play
the field I also think it's a reason I
don't really like porn that much because
sex without context is just mechanics to
me it's boring the build up of desire
that's the interesting part and the
struggle between desire and shame I
shouldn't but I want to that's how you
build a plotline kids I'm also guessing
this kind of slow burn sexuality is more
common in women than men and I wonder if
that's a reason why gay men tend to know
they're gay at an earlier age than gay
women when you have teenage boy
testosterone levels it's harder to be
agnostic or mistaken about who you're
attracted to whereas there's a lot of
gay women who don't realize they're gay
until they're in their 30s or even later
and thank God for them they make me feel
less bad about my wasted youth so it's
hard for me to use visual sexual
interest as a guide to my sexuality
because I do feel aesthetic attraction
towards Beautiful People of any gender
and that can be pretty intense in its
own right I guess the difference for me
is looking at a beautiful woman is more
emotionally captivating to me than
looking at a beautiful man which can be
moving in its own way but it's more like
the way I'm moved by by I don't know the
paron you know is sturdy symmetrical has
impressive columns it's not to say it's
totally asexual I mean I'd [ __ ] the
Parthenon I'd [ __ ] it so hard I admit I
do have some kind of erotic fascination
with masculinity and maybe that stems
from my pre-transition sense of having
failed at masculinity so I'm mesmerized
by the real thing there's something
about the contrast between me and a
masculine man that's sexually intriguing
to me like I've sometimes pleasantly
gasped at the feeling of hairy muscly
arms enfolding my smooth fragile body or
maybe it's more Freudian the masculine
man as Daddy the archetypal father the
symbolic power of the phace penetration
is the ultimate expression of desire and
possession there's a lot of sexual
connotations to manhood and I think
that's why I can look at a sexy man and
create plausible fantasies in my head
where I'd absolutely enjoy letting him
do things to me and I can find things I
like about male bodies like uh they're
very warm uh I love it when you get
under the covers with a man and he warms
you up but that's when the lesbian voice
comes into my head and she says but are
you attracted to men or do you just like
being warm my attraction to women is
very different I look at a beautiful
woman and it's just like Oh no you're
gorgeous you're
beautiful this is going to destroy me
you know what can actually be painful
how beautiful a woman is I've never once
been in pain over male Beauty but around
Joanne once I was open about my feelings
and things got bad there'd be moments
I'd have to just look away from her and
be like don't even enter my line of
sight right now you're too beautiful I
can't stand it there's a kind of sick
masochism and wanting someone who
doesn't want you back it's insatiable
like an addiction and on the flip side
there's an intense erotic thrill in
being desired I think that's what got me
interested in men in the first place
it's that they
interested in me and that's pretty
interesting I've felt desired by men in
a way I've never truly felt desired by
women you know a man will glow at you
with that agitated carnivorous
desperation [ __ ] me up King God that's
hot gets me every time but notice how
excitement at the attention the flattery
of being desired is not the same thing
as attraction to men you know there's a
difference between I want you and I like
that you want me but for a long time I
confused one for the other and one
reason I was able to do that is that the
normative sexual role for women is to be
pursued possessed desired seduced
dominated by men it's all very passive
and in most of the sexual encounters
I've had with men I've taken a very
submissive role sometimes I just submit
to the glower and let him do things to
me and I do think that the thrill of
being desired is a valid thing to want I
like that feeling myself and I do
genuinely enjoy taking on a more
submissive role sometimes but you have
to go about it thoughtfully because if
you don't sexual submission can be a way
to avoid confronting what your desires
actually are it's freedom from freedom
and if you're ashamed of your sexual
orientation and ashamed of your
transsexual body and ashamed of having
any sexual feeling at all because of
stigma about trans women being
fetishists then relinquishing
responsibility for your own desires by
letting someone else take control can be
the only way you can enjoy sex at all
and for a while it was almost the only
way I could enjoy it and I was able to
convince myself that was normal because
the sexual situation of a lot of sis
straight women isn't really that much
more liberated like I Read 50 Shades of
Gray years ago and totally identified
with the fantasy and later I thought
that was evidence I had normative female
desires never mind that I was
identifying with the midlife crisis
fantasies of a repressed English
housewife Longing To Be brutalized by a
capitalist Tyrant I mean not to shame
women who genuinely do enjoy a healthier
version of that fantasy I think a lot of
women pointlessly suffer under a kind of
feminist guilt about that but what makes
me different is that for me submission
to a man was simply the only way I could
enjoy sex without shame and that's a lot
of what what I did for a couple years
even though my real sexual attraction is
to women whereas even in the most
patriarchal situation straight women are
ultimately attracted to men and sexually
aroused by male bodies or are they gay
men certainly are and gay women are just
rapaic about women but a lot of straight
women are just kind of n about male
bodies and men in general which what is
that about I just I just do not stand
straight women I don't think I ever will
and that's okay I'm just going to accept
my bewilderment and move on with my
lesbian life now what I've been giving
you so far is a retrospective analysis
an autopsy of my romantic failings of
the last 2 years but you have to
understand that when I was living
through this I experienced it very
differently because I didn't have these
insights so I wasn't thinking oh I'm not
really attracted to men but I enjoy the
thrill of being desired by them so I'm
going to pursue that to dist ract myself
from how ashamed I am of my attraction
to women no subconsciously I put my
attraction to women on mute at least
until Joanne ruined my life and I
genuinely thought I was attracted to men
which was a lot more than just a
frivolous sexual fantasy I had a serious
long-term boyfriend for a year and a
half who I had very genuine feelings for
plot twist story time so my ex-boyfriend
let's call
him Chad oh and he was a chad like full
gigachad fantasy you know he was very
masculine taller than me objectively
attractive very Charming straight women
used to tell me all the time they were
jealous of me for being with him and
obviously I loved that to me Chad
represented almost an ideal of manhood a
sort of archetypal romantic lead who
swept me off my feet and fulfilled my
sick fantasies of being a heterosexual
woman now you probably think I'm going
to say that he was just an abstract fan
FY to me but that once it came to
actually dating I realized I didn't like
it but honestly it's more complicated
than that like at the beginning I was
the one who pursued him and I still
think of him as the one genuine Boy
Crush of my life when we started dating
it was really exciting I'd never had a
boyfriend before and he'd never been
with a transom before and we had this
like adorably hetosexual energy together
like holding hands in the park it was
cute this would be a better lesbian
story story if Chad was a cad but he
wasn't he was great he took very good
care of me he was never ashamed to be
seen with me or of his friends and
family knowing he was dating me which if
you're a transom that's a huge deal he
was a lot less ashamed of me than I am
of myself and when I was with him I
wasn't ashamed and that meant a lot so I
really wanted this to work like if I was
going to be with a man he was the one
won and for a year or so I thought it
was working I enjoyed the time we spent
together I missed him when he was gone I
told him I loved him and I meant it but
what happened is by the end of the first
year the initial excitement had died
down and while Chad was ready to keep
escalating the
relationship I was realizing that
something was very seriously emotionally
wrong on my end there was something
missing and when I realized I was in
love with Joan
I was like there's that missing feeling
and I started to understand what my
problem was then last full I posted to
Instagram an aloof picture of me with
the caption do I actually like men or do
I just like attention and I didn't mean
anything serious by that I was just
joking around you know you can post
something like that and a bunch of
straight women will respond like yeah
[ __ ]
men what is their damage well they're
stuck dating men that's their damage but
if few people left comments saying oh
are you making a video about compet you
should make a video about compat and I
was like what the [ __ ] is compet so I
Googled it and I learned that compet is
short for compulsory heterosexuality
basically it's the idea that
heterosexuality is socially required of
women and it's so bound up with the
conventional idea of what it even means
to be a woman that gay women often
mistakenly believe for years that
they're attracted to men and this Google
gole search led me to a Reddit post
called the Amia lesbian Master do and
I'm reading through this post like oh no
this sounds terribly familiar quote
compulsory heterosexuality is the voice
in my head that says I must really be H
even when I'm in love with a woman quote
you have every reason to be happy in
your relationship with a man but you
just aren't everything is going really
well but something is missing and you
can't figure out what so next thing you
know I'm doing heila shots at 3:00 a.m.
and taking Ami lesbian internet quizzes
that were clearly designed for
13-year-olds and I'm fully a 31-year-old
transexual taking this quiz like it's
true Samantha was right I am a total
lesz all the cisg people watching this
video probably want to kill me right now
cuz y'all figured this [ __ ] out in high
school and I'm sitting here in my 30s
like it's just I just I just can't I
just well can I be a melodramatic baby
gay for 30 minutes of my lifetime please
is that all right with you the
so to be honest I still experience
compet thoughts and Fantasies like for a
long time I've had what seemed to be
romantic fantasies about marrying a man
but after a lot of introspection I've
realized that this is not really a
fantasy of private happiness and
fulfillment it's a fantasy of social
Prestige and acceptance like can you
imagine if I got married to a tall
handsome man at an opulent wedding with
lots of photographers posting to
Instagram ah I'd be Queen of the
[ __ ] I'd be super heck and valid ooo
but I don't actually want to be married
I want to get married I want to have a
wedding basically I want to wear a
wedding dress I want attention Okay
please pay pay attention to me so I can
totally deconstruct the fantasy but is
still really hard for me to let it go I
cling to the reassuring Conformity of
heterosexuality because there's a level
of gender ins ability and deviancy
that's inherent to homosexuality and
until recently I wasn't secure enough in
my gender to handle that lesbianism is a
very advanced form of Womanhood and I
think I needed to go through the more
101 straight girl experience before
attempting anything as difficult as that
I still have a hard time imagining a
happy future for myself as a woman
partnered to a woman and I think that's
partly because good lesbian
representation in media is so sparse the
best we have is a Showtime melodrama
from 15 years ago which I do like and I
like the new one too but after that the
runner up is I mean maybe not the
lesbian representation we need it's a
YouTube show about two drag queens whom
we ship well I don't ship them because I
have a fully lesbian parasocial internet
crush on kacha zala don't laugh at me
she's smart she's funny she's beautiful
that's everything I'm looking for in a
woman sure some haters and losers will
probably try to convince me that katcha
is in fact a homosexual man posing as a
woman but you know what this is a super
[ __ ] vulnerable moment in my life and
I don't need this right
now I need to be touched by a real woman
I'm I'm losing my goddamn mind it's so
deeply embedded in our culture that
marrying a man is the end goal of
Womanhood and it's not just Disney
movies like it's the Bible it's Greek
mythology German fairy tales Victorian
novels the whole weight of cultural
history is is telling you that what it
means to succeed as a woman is to marry
a man and if you're already super
dysphoric and insecure about your gender
than to reject that possibility ah it
hurts it hurts so bad but whenever I
think about having a long-term partner
you know not the wedding day but the
1,000th morning waking up
together I can only imagine her being a
woman my brain wants a good man to take
care of me but my heart wants a high
mainten and stea to ruin my life and
once I knew that for
sure I thought it would be wrong to stay
with Chad and this man was like my hinge
he was holding me together but last
December I broke up with him because I'm
a lesbian
which at least is a good
reason I'm having a hard time you guys
leave your pity in the comments and I'm
starting to regret eating this fruit too
I feel like [ __ ] I think it's the loss
of My Immortal Soul Weighing on me I
could really use a couple Advil and a
vodka tonic I think I might throw some
clothes on too where's that
[Music]
snake I already missed my heterosexual
Nails I know these are too long to be
gay but baby steps okay this is hard for
me getting my acrylics removed
traumatizing I feel like I'm
de-transitioning one of these days I
will do the lesbian manicure with
acrylics on eight fingers I just have to
find the courage to walk into a salon
and say hi I'm a homosexual please I
want two short nails so I can [ __ ]
[ __ ] shame let's talk about the shame
before I was
transgendered I really only dated women
though two of those women later turned
out to be trans so I guess we had some
way of finding each other an attraction
to women was never really a problem for
me before the transgendering because I
was raised in an alternative lifestyle
where men are supposed to be attracted
to women crazy I know not that I'm a
newcomer to shame because oh sweaty I
was doing plenty of things that men are
not supposed to do and before I
transitioned my shame was centered
around my being at the time a gender
non-conforming man which in my early
YouTube videos I dealt with by
caricaturing myself and basically
leaning into the public humiliation one
of my my classic techniques but now my
shame is centered around my failure to
be a socially acceptable woman and the
most glaring aspects of that failure are
my male past my sexual
orientation and the severed human heads
in my refrigerator yeah killing all
those people was not my most feminine
moment but I was having a bad skin day
what was I supposed to do so there's two
problems that kind of multiply together
one I'm ashamed of being trans two I'm
ashamed of being a lesbian and whatever
1 time 2 is I'm really ashamed of being
a trans lesbian GH and it's difficult
and risky for me to admit these feelings
because visible queer people are
supposed to perform Pride why is no one
talking about the shame because we are
ashamed of the shame but we shouldn't be
the shame is a natural result of shaming
I grew up in a media era when trans
women were usually presented as vomit
inducing monstrosities who deserve the
violence they bring upon themselves by
existing and I started my transition in
the first year of the Trump
Administration when there's been
constant vilification of trans people in
the Press invading women's bathrooms
forcing our Insanity on children
destroying Western Civilization with our
authoritarian pronouns it's hard to
express just the daily humiliation of
being a transwoman under these
conditions and then there's the little
jobs people throw at you like my laser
technician recently told me you must be
very courageous to transition because
that is not socially acceptable and then
she went back to blasting laser beams
into my [ __ ] and then there's the
internet where you know I used to spend
most of my life before the sadness took
over and I'm sure we all know that
people on the internet are a wretched
wretched horde of bigoted Attack
Helicopters the whole point of this
channel is I try to talk sense to these
people I talk to the turfs and the
conservatives and I try to empathize
with their point of view and provide a
rational response but a side effect of
all that research is I've acquired a
burgeoning vocabulary of self-loathing
it seeped into my brain and become a
part of me and this lifelong buildup of
Shame has become a wound at the heart of
my existence and all I can really do
about it is compensate by wearing fancy
clothes I may be trash but I am Majestic
trash I am rendant trash I am coutur
trash and I just bought a midcentury
gold trimmed Venetian Bloom glass de
caner which helps me forget the shame
and self-loathing that plagues my every
moment now I'm guessing that a lot of
people will be confused about why I'm so
ashamed of being gay when I've already
come out as trans which seems like a
bigger deal to paraphrase what some
people have told me you're already a
transgendered and a freak's a freak so
who cares what kind of freak well first
of all I would like to propose a
sociological Theory Tiffany's law all
freaks have a deep psychological need to
feel Superior to a different type of
freak and trans lesbians are pretty
close to the bottom of that packing
order who's even left for me to feel
superior to the goddamn belgians [ __ ]
this waffle second coming out as trans
wasn't as hard for me because I did it
incrementally over like 8 years at first
I was like well I'm just a man who wears
makeup sometimes then I was like
actually it's not just clothes and
makeup but I'm actually pretty genter
non-conforming in a lot of ways and then
I realized I'm not a man at all and I
identified as non binary then I started
taking hormones in 2 months on HRT I
woke up one day and said it's fine I'm
literally a woman so by the time I
actually came out as a trans woman that
was actually a step up in terms of
social acceptability from where I was
before when I was a gender queer gender
[ __ ] I felt like I didn't fit in
anywhere whereas when I started
transitioning to female even though at
first I had a lot of the same problems
there was at least a goal in mind some
possible future where I could lead a
normal ish Life as a woman so the moment
I started identifying as a woman was the
moment The compet Voice entered my head
sure I've never been very attracted to
men before but maybe I'm attracted to
them now I'm a woman right I've always
been a little by curious and there was
that time I kissed a boy when I was
drunk maybe I can make this work let's
choose some boys to be attracted to and
get started on this of course I wasn't
as self-aware as that my way of
explaining it to myself was I guess
hormones just magically changed my
sexual orientation to the socially
acceptable one that's super freaking
crazy shut up you godamn lesbo God
there's so much pressure on trans women
to be extremely gender conforming and
even more so if you're a representative
of the community you feel like you have
to be a Stepford Wife or else CIS people
are going to throw us all in camps and
early in my transition I kind of
worshiped straight trans women like I
looked up to them and I wanted to be
just like them now back then there were
a handful of trans lesbians on YouTube
trying to make the case to the masses
that being a trans lesbian is a
legitimate thing but in 2017 sweaty the
masses were not having it I watched
those women get eaten alive and as a
result of my witnessing that at a super
[ __ ] vulnerable moment for me I
internalized the message that a trans
lesbian is just not an okay thing to be
if you want to be tolerated or respected
by anybody other than a handful of
Communists so I began my transition with
essentially no role model of a widely
respected and admired trans lesbian and
it doesn't help that most forms of
transphobia are harsher on gay trans
women than they are on straight trans
women like could take this Trope that
trans women are men who transition to
creep on women in bathrooms in response
to that it feels really good to be able
to say I'm not even attracted to women
I'm just a petite heterosexual bio girl
I'm surely not some kind of six-foot
monster who likes women shame shame it
does make me feel like a monster
sometimes like a mutant that has no
place in society and this shame has
actually made it more difficult for me
to accept that I'm a gay woman than it
was for me to come out as Trans in the
first place it's like I made a kind of
subconscious bargain where I traded my
sexual orientation for my gender
identity so I finally transitioned only
to spend the next couple years living
with a different kind of denial and that
denial got pretty deep and pretty dark
this is painful and incriminating to
admit but not all of my shame came from
external bigotry some of it came from my
own judgment and disgust toward things I
saw trans lesbians doing like this anime
Catgirl [ __ ] which clearly gets under my
skin and not just because these people
have been harassing me for 3 years like
you see it all over trans Twitter in
Reddit this queasy combination of the
hypersexual and the infantile I'm a
hecking Catgirl lesbian klut Meow Meow
Girl dick here's the 97th picture of my
own legs and thigh high stripy socks
oooo what is that about is this how
women act sis people are going to see
this
they're not going to let us into women's
spaces if we act like that now I'm not
proud of having these judgmental
feelings but I confess to periodically
sinking into these morbid guilty binges
of cringing at embarrassing trans
lesbians and if I was a different type
of YouTuber I could have turned this
into content at my worst I would sit
there telling another trans person why
are trans lesbians so cringey they're
making things harder for the rest of us
girls and that's the real darkness isn't
it not even having the decency to openly
despise yourself like an honest American
no just sitting there in absurd denial
of who you are as a person disparaging
your own repressed identity to anyone
who will listen and I'm ashamed of that
too I'm ashamed I sunk that low but all
you can do is try to get better and I'm
trying to get better I've broken free of
the denial and now I have to break free
of the shame because shame is literally
ruining my life I told Joanne I was
working on a video about shame and she
said I might want to mention that one of
the reasons she didn't want to be with
me is she'd be ashamed to date another
transwoman she said she feels like
relationships between trans women are
freakish behavior on the outskirts of
society with no attempt to integrate
these are very painful words to hear
from the woman you're in love with but I
understand why she feels that way Joanne
gets validation from dating CIS men or
CIS women but I can't be the h
that connects her to mainstream society
and it's maddening to me that she feels
that way because I would have chosen her
over every CIS woman in the world but
I'm just another worthless freak without
the authority of society behind me so my
love doesn't count shame it poisons the
soul you know who you love just like
what gender you are is such a basic part
of your humanity and shame about that
cuts to the core of your being it's not
I'm ashamed of what I did it's not I'm
ashamed of how I I feel it's I'm ashamed
of who and what I am and living in that
state of mind is is garbage it's it's
basically hell even after I realized my
sexuality I considered just shoving that
[ __ ] back down never coming out I have
all these fears about it I'm worried
people will take my gender less
seriously I'm worried CIS women or
straight women I'm friends with will get
weird about it I'm worried I'll die a
lonely useless lesbian in which case I
should have just married a man cuz at
least then there'd be some to kill the
spiders and fix the [ __ ] sink I'm
worried I'll lose my straight male
audience on YouTube although I mean love
you boys and please keep the attention
coming cuz I need all the validation I
can get right now but I will be fine
without you and in any case when is a
woman's being a lesbian ever stopped a
man from taking a swing at it I actually
thought about marrying a man anyway just
sacrificing my sexual orientation to
regain that safe comfortable Shameless
feeling I used to have when walking down
the street holding Chad's hand hand
feeling like I'd succeeded as a woman
but if I don't deal with this now and
work towards accepting myself then I'm
just going to be in the same situation
in 10 years when I'm 41 years old and
married to a man and having these same
feelings so it's time for this to stop
because literally the only good thing
about being gay is doing gay [ __ ] and as
long as I'm ashamed of my sexuality no
one's going to want to do gay [ __ ] with
me as I like to say if you can't love
yourself how in the hell you going to
prop up your narcissistic delusions look
I'm trying to stay positive Maybe maybe
everyone hates trans lesbians now but
just you wait we all know how Trends
work in 10 years being a trans lesbian
will be the coolest hippest chicest
thing imaginable and all the people who
talk [ __ ] now will forget they ever said
a word that's right even the straight
trans girls will be making out with each
other just for the clout like we can be
lesbians too we are ay oh it's going to
be Madonna and Britney at the 2003 VMAs
all over again mark my words and among
CIS lesbians oh it will actually be a
sign of prestige to have a trap
waifu I Can Dream right once you tasted
one forbidden fruit why stop there
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]